nous
justice responsabilité urgence ce sont
les propres termes du premier ministre
présentant sa réforme de la sécurité
sociale
d'abord basé sur une plus grande
maîtrise des dépenses de santé mais
aussi une cotisation spéciale de
remboursement de la dette et
l'augmentation de certaines cotisations
invité du journal le ministre des
affaires sociales mais sur jacques
barrot brême simone veil tu marques
seconde élection présidentielle en
algérie c'est demain soir ce soir dans
la deuxième partie le journal édition
spéciale les enjeux de cette première
véritable élection d'un chef d'état en
algérie depuis l'indépendance en 1960
madame monsieur bonsoir le plan de
réformes et de réduction du déficit de
la sécurité sociale présenté cet après
midi par le premier ministre peut se
diviser en deux grands chapitres d'abord
la réduction du déficit par une
cotisation spéciale de 0.5 % sur tous
les revenus et d'autre part une nouvelle
méthode de fonctionnement plus
rationnelle et mieux surveiller de la
sécurité sociale dans son ensemble des
médecins et des malades aussi en
particulier avec en premier lieu la
généralisation du carnet médical qui
devrait permettre de maîtriser les
dépenses de santé et sanctionner le cas
échéant malades et médecins
ce qui va changer dans votre vie
quotidienne elisabeth est bientôt
indispensable dans la panoplie de
lescure et une nouvelle carte avec photo
pour lutter contre la fraude et un
carnet médical a présenté aux médecins à
chaque consultation
sinon pas de remboursement ni pour les
soins ni pour les médicaments
le carnet devra aussi incité le malade à
consulter d'abord son généraliste avant
de s'adresser à un spécialiste
côté pharmacie davantage de médicaments
génériques de même composition que les
autres mais vendus moins chers et moins
de gaspillage puisque les pharmaciens
pourront distribuer exactement la
quantité de gélules ou dans pool
nécessaires à un traitement
quand ton médecin ils devront limiter
leurs prescriptions à ce qui sera prévu
chaque année par le parlement
sinon ils ne pourront pas augmenter le
tarif de leur consultation
enfin pour développer la prévention les
médecins de ville seront incités à
s'orienter vers la médecine du travail
ou scolaire qui manque d'effectif
maîtrise des dépenses de santé cela veut
aussi dire pour le premier ministre
surveillance des caisses de la sécurité
sociale par l'assemblée d'abord qui
fixera les grandes orientations
financières régionalisation du contrôle
du fonctionnement des hôpitaux cliniques
réactions des intéressés
jean-paul chapelle une journée comme les
autres pour le docteur henry en
découvrant cet après midi les mesures
concernant sa profession ce généraliste
parisien n'a rien trouvé de
révolutionnaire ils restent encore
sceptiques sur l'efficacité du carnet
médical
la seule recommandation qui est faite
aux patients et de le montrer à chaque
médecin qu'il consultera donc rien de l'
empêche de voir plusieurs médecins dans
la même journée le médecin rien ne
l'empêchent de faire la consultation
mais bien sûr que va le médecin fait sa
consultation signe le carnet médical
pour que son patient soit soit remboursé
même la menace de sanctions sur les
médecins qui dépasseront les objectifs
fixés ne fait pas peur au dr dre comme
la moitié des médecins parisiens
ces honoraires reste libre on si on n'a
pas une sanction pécuniaire autres
direct soit sous forme d'un
remboursement de une certaine somme
d'argent en fonction de du dépassement
que l'on aura
si on n'a pas ça me rend en effet elle
ne me concerne pas tout à fait
directement si les médecins de base
gardent leur flegme certains de leurs
leaders syndicaux eux montent au créneau
pour défendre la corporation aujourd'hui
on ne s'occupe plus c'était besoins
médicaux des populations on s'occupe de
la des nécessités budgétaires
je crois que nous professionnels ont dit
nous sommes garants de la qualité des
soins et nous dirons cela aux assurés
sociaux nous dirons cela à toute la
population française est ce qu'elle
accepte d'être rationner sur le plan de
la santé
une voix critiquent un peu isolés dans
leur ensemble les médecins trouvent
assez doux le remède annoncé ce soir
pour soigner la série maîtrise des
dépenses de santé eau mais aussi
rentrées financières création d'une
cotisation spéciale sur tous les revenus
pour rembourser à terme la dette
actuelle de la sécurité sociale sur une
dizaine d'années m étais yannick
letranchant rds le sigle ne figure pas
encore dans le dictionnaire
il pourrait pourtant bientôt rejoindre
sa grande soeur la csg la contribution
sociale généralisée crds cela veut dire
remboursement de la dette sociale c'est
le nouveau prélèvement pour la sécu il
est institué à partir du 1er janvier 96
et normalement pour 13 ans un taux
unique 0,5 pour cent il frappera plus
largement que l'actuel csg tous les
revenus sauf le minimum vieillesse le
rmi les allocations handicapés et les
revenus du livret a
exemple 50 francs par mois pour un
revenu de 10 mille francs 31 francs pour
un smic
les retraités qui paie aujourd'hui
l'impôt sur le revenu et les chômeurs
indemnisés au dessus du smic verront
aussi leurs cotisations maladie
augmentent et 1,2 point 296 1,2 encore
en 1997 les allocations familiales ne
seront pas revalorisés en 1996 elle
échappe actuellement à l'impôt sur le
revenu ce ne sera plus le cas à partir
de 97
quant à l'entrée en vigueur de la
prestation autonomie prévue pour le 1er
janvier 1996 elle est reportée au 1er
janvier de l'année suivante
et à côté de ces mesures alain juppé a
aussi annoncé une réforme
institutionnelle ainsi c'est l'assemblée
nationale qui fixera l'évolution des
dépenses de santé la gestion des quais
sera régionalisée les 19 régime
spécifique d'assurance maladie seront
fondus en un seul
pour l'avenir l'assiette de la csg va
être élargie à d'autres revenus que ceux
des salariés les allocations familiales
vont être soumises à l'impôt et les
cotisations maladie des retraités
imposables et des chômeurs indemnisés au
dessus du smic seront donc relevé de 1,2
point dès 1996
exemple concret et nous avons rendu
visite à un couple de retraités qui est
concerné par les décisions annoncées cet
après-midi sébastien guilbert pascal
pays pierre et louisette ont un peu de
mal à s'y retrouver entre la retraite de
la sécu la retraite complémentaire la
csg les cotisations maladie pas évident
de calculer ce qui leur reste à la fin
du mois au total il touche à eux deux
nets par mois
quatorze mille 700 francs une retraite
que pierre ancien ajusteur métallos et
louisette jadis ouvriers en électronique
estime confortable mais méritée nous
considérons en tant que retraité d'avoir
plié professionnelles et cotisations
maladie à partir de là on a vraiment
remplir d'autres missions de naturel
social et de salariés
deux mesures du gouvernement vont
affecter directement leur retraite
l'augmentation du taux de cotisation
maladie et l'application de l'impôt
baptisé rds
concrètement ce sont donc environ 260
francs supplémentaires qui leur seront
retirés tous les mois de leur retraite
pierre et louisette savent qu'ils
devront faire l'effort mais s'inquiète
quand même de voir leur pouvoir d'achat
s'amoindrir on pourrait profiter
davantage alors c'est vrai que bien
souvent on pense à nouveau petit on les
aide mais je trouve que tout ce qu'on va
nous donner en voit tout ce qu'on va
nous retirer et bien on n'en fera pas
bénéficier les autres dit pour nous
n'est puni pour nos petits enfants
pierre et louisette s'apprête à payer
davantage en pensant à rémy leur petit
fils à son avenir et à celui de la
sécurité sociale
il faut aussi dire que l'idée à terme du
gouvernement est de réduire le nombre
des caisses d'assurance-maladie ajoutons
à cela la mise en place d'une commission
chargée d'examiner pour les
fonctionnaires l'allongement de la
cotisation vieillesse de 37 ans et demi
à 40 ans comme c'est déjà le cas pour le
secteur privé également annoncé le
report de la mise en oeuvre de la
prestation autonomie pour les personnes
âgées dépendantes au 1er janvier juillet
pardon 1990 revenons sur l'un des mots
clés du discours du premier ministre la
responsabilisation de tous les acteurs
de la sécurité sociale en france il
faudra que dans les régions les dépenses
des hôpitaux soient mieux maîtrisée est
mieux répartie exemple à castres et
mazamet isabelle de lyon gilbert usant
castres un hôpital important près de
15000 admission par an un des pôles des
midi-pyrénées mazamet une structure
beaucoup plus petit mais indispensable
pour les habitants des vallées alentours
7 km entre les deux villes
jouer la complémentarité des hôpitaux
une évidence aujourd'hui l'idée est
venue des médecins ça permet de partager
nos expériences notre notre potentialité
on
des différentes spécialités et on peut
pas savoir tout et tout faire en même
temps donc c'est important d'avoir une
équipe multidisciplinaire dans tous les
domaines
depuis 92 plusieurs conventions ont été
signées entre les deux établissements
le scanner la réanimation lourdes sont à
castres mais les blocs opératoires
circulent à la demande et certains
spécialistes passent d'un hôpital à
l'autre plus de frais de transport de
malades la complémentarité n'implique
pas forcément des économies mais permet
à chaque hôpital de garder ces secteurs
de pointe de mieux affecter l'argent
dont ils disposent et l'offrir un
meilleur service aux patients le fait qu
un grand hôpital fournissent ces moyens
potentiel un hôpital voisin permet par
ce comportement de moyens et de
techniques de matérial d'éviter certains
de remise en cause
l'idéal serait de réunir les deux
établissements en un seul à mi chemin
mais l'investissement est trop lourd
chacun des hôpitaux une cascade un des
points forts il faut donc qu'on vous ait
donné à chaque hôpital sur les moyens de
développer ses activités chez prend feu
et s'il n'y a pas ça la complémentarité
et jarry vient de la lecture et paul
annexion à celui contre castres et
mazamet se rendent compte aujourd'hui
qu'il est difficile d'aller plus loin
sans rompre l'équilibré premier ministre
a bien précisé d'ailleurs cet après midi
que les performances des services des
hôpitaux qu'ils soient grands ou petits
serait évalué et que les moins
performants pourront être supprimés en
conclusion de son discours du jour cet
après midi à l'assemblée nationale le
premier ministre monsieur juppé a tenu à
situer l'ampleur de sa réforme il ne
s'agit pas at il dit en posant la
question de confiance
de la simple survie d'un gouvernement
monsieur juppé
l'addition des corporatismes des
égoïsmes qui existent et qui se
manifesteront je le sais ne saurait
arrêter notre élan
si le sens des responsabilités la
primauté de l'intérêt général la volonté
de partage et de solidarité l'emportent
nous allons réussir ce qu'on n'a pas osé
entreprendre depuis 30 ans il faut le
faire jade l intime conviction il faut
le faire maintenant et il faut le faire
ensemble ce n'est pas le sort d'un
gouvernement qui est se joue c'est un
enjeu national qui est en cause
je vous demande donc je demande un autre
majorité de m'apporter son soutien sans
état d'âme et sans arrière pensée voilà
monsieur barreau bonsoir d'une dure
journée pour vous qui avez préparé ce
plan qui a été présenté aujourd'hui
avant des remarques générales que vous
pourriez faire
voyant venir tout d'abord un aspect qui
nous touchent de près nos patients
malades potentiels c'est la sphère du
carnet médical ce carnet médical
j'ai bien compris il va être obligatoire
et nous serons suivis par un seul
médecin n'auront plus d'autres
possibilités que cela non il s'agit pas
de remettre en cause la liberté de choix
du médecin s'agit simplement de guider
en quelque sorte l'assuré social dans le
système de soins est d'éviter que il n'a
y d'un médecin à l'autre faisant des
analyses
il s'agit d'éviter des abus mais avant
que je réponds à votre question laissez
moi dire un petit mot de ce que j'ai
ressenti soir à l'assemblée en écoutant
alain juppé en voyant la manière dont
les parlementaires ont réagi je me
disais là où est le courage là n'est la
confiance et simone veil est là si le
régime de retraite aujourd'hui suscite à
nouveau une confiance c'est parce
qu'elle a pris les mesures difficiles
courageuses et bien moi je dis que là où
est le courage l'année la confiance
ceci étant dit pour les français car
mais la raison mais aujourd'hui pour les
français c'est pas c'est par un
bouleversement
c'est simplement la volonté de mettre
fin à un certain nombre d'abus que nous
connaissons tous les uns les autres
parfois on a tendance à penser qu'avec
le voisin qui
com s et à vue et puis nous comme étant
nous aussi un peu et le carnet de suivi
médical permet justement par exemple de
passer de son médecin à l'hôpital de
challans de temps en temps sans avoir à
recommencer l'ensemble des analyses et
puis je dirais que c'est la manière
d'être bien soignés
parce qu'être bien soigné ce n'est pas
en recevoir sans cesse des ordonnances
qui s'empilaient sur les os c'est aussi
d'avoir un effet quelqu'un qui vous dit
monsieur barroso qu'il vous fait
monsieur barreau cet après midi monsieur
juppé a beaucoup basé son discours sur
la responsabilité à la fois de ceux qui
auront à surveiller les caisses des
médecins et même des malades ça veut
dire que vous compter beaucoup sur soi
et l'ensemble sur le civisme des
français ça veut dire quelque chose de
plus précis c'est à dire que désormais
on à clarifier les responsabilités
le parlement par exemple eelv et battait
il débattait mini ne votais jamais il ne
tranche est jamais eh bien il va
maintenant faire partie de cette chaîne
des décisions et puis il y aura toujours
les partenaires sociaux mais il y aura
un lien entre l' enveloppe nationale
fixée par le parlement
et puis ce qui se passe dans les régions
il y aura des liens entre les directeurs
des caisses primaires et le directeur de
la caisse nationale
tout ça pour pouvoir guider le système
pour éviter que sur le plan régional on
dérape
sans s'en apercevoir il va y avoir donc
une chaîne de responsabilités claires et
puis des règles du jeu qui évite en
effet tous ces abus qui nous ont amenés
là alors vous l'avez entendu les
retraités qui était interrogé tout à
l'heure comprenez d'une certaine façon
segmentation mais il regrettait tout de
même qu'après avoir cotisé toute leur
existence de travail il est encore à le
faire aujourd'hui est que cette
cotisation soit augmenté les retraités
ils ne cotisent plus bien sûr pour la
retraite
heureusement ils l'ont gagné cette
retraite et à la fin de la guerre il
avait des retraites tellement faible
qu'on leur avait dit bon pour
l'assurance maladie
ce n'est pas normal que vous payez mais
maintenant les retraites ont rejoints
pour certaines d'entre elles pour la
majorité d'entre elles les revenus des
actifs pourquoi voulez vous qu'on
continue à demander un acte i pour le
même revenu pour le même niveau de
revenus 1,4 pour cent et puis pour
l'actif 6 il y avait 8 et puis pour le
retraité 1,4 pour cent et bien quelque
chose qui n'est pas tout à fait juste
alors je sais bien que pour les
retraités c'est un effort je suis
convaincu qu'ils ont tous une âme de
grands-pères et grands-mères et qu'ils
savent qui n'est pas normal que le petit
fils qui va travailler qui va travailler
au smic paye 6,8 et que ne paye que 1,4
donc je suis convaincu qu'ils auront
l'esprit de solidarité bien on se
retrouve dans un instant car nous allons
interroger madame veil et nous avons
monsieur marc blondel qui n'est pas tout
à fait d'accord avec vous vous
l'imaginez mais avant cela après le
discours de monsieur juppé cet après
midi j'aurai que nous écoutions
maintenant les réactions dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée nationale roland
sicard frédéric de large en passant dans
les couloirs alain juppé a dû s'en
rendre compte aujourd'hui ça allait bien
dans l'hémicycle archi comble le premier
ministre avait dû avoir la même
impression la majorité debout pour
l'applaudir c'est bien le signe que le
courant est passé
et si alain juppé avait pu entendre
toutes les déclarations faites après son
discours alors il n'aurait plus eu de
doute cet après-midi la droite toute la
droite apprécié son discours j'en
approuve l'essentiel
et j'y ai retrouvé bien des
préoccupations qui sont les miennes
voilà enfin un gouvernement qui
s'attaque aux vraies causes du déficit
de la sécurité sociale
on a eu un homme qui connaît son dossier
qui a été au fond des choses qui a parlé
avec son coeur et qui a fait de la
politique parce qu'il a été courageux
c'est courageux et comme il l'a dit on
n'avait rien fait depuis un certain
nombre de décennies
lui l'a fait la majorité qui fait bloc
c'est donc dans l'opposition que se sont
concentrées les critiques
une position qui ne rejette pas tout
mais qui monte tout de même au créneau
je suis opposé à la manière dont le
premier ministre veut faire porter
l'effort sur les uns et sur les autres
là dessus je crois qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup à faire pour améliorer la copie
du premier ministre ça va coûter cher
aux français je persiste à dire
e
nous irons nous allons aller vers une
diminution de la consommation une
augmentation du chômage et par
conséquent encore plus de difficultés
pour la seigneurie des autres en tout
cas pour alain juppé l'objectif est
atteint sa majorité ressouder sa réforme
de la protection sociale va pouvoir être
mises en oeuvre
le premier ministre a tant dit un
électrochoc pour rebondir ce soir
beaucoup de ses amis la firme il l'a
peut être trouvées bien réaction madame
simone veil vous aviez en charge des
affaires sociales monsieur va re lisez
tout à l'heure est-ce que vous avez
sentiment qu'on va continuer ce que vous
aviez entrepris et que je crois que nous
avons mis en place beaucoup
d'instruments qui aujourd'hui sont
utilisés dans une réforme qui va plus
loin que plus ambitieuse qui vraiment
réforme les structures et je dois dire
que je voudrais en féliciter ici le plus
important comme l'a souligné jacques
barrot c'est la clarification des
responsabilités puisque maintenant le
parlement grâce à une réforme
constitutionnelle votre âge je crois que
c'est très important
l'évolution des dépenses il y aura donc
une possibilité de contrôle
parlementaire qui n'existaient pas et
s'il ya une augmentation puisque les
gens ont l'air de douter de l'efficacité
si une augmentation gouvernement devra
rendre des comptes y aura des sanctions
qui seront prises
ensuite des fonctions aussi contre les
médecins qui n'auront pas respecté les
les objectifs qui leur sont fixés avec
des ajustements de rénumération il ya
donc les outils à la fois les
responsabilités sont définis et des
outils qui permettent d'appliquer
réellement les décisions et je crois que
c'est très important je crois que c'est
important aussi qu'en fait le
paritarisme soit enfin éclairci
c'est à dire que c'est le paritarisme
c'est le la répartition des pouvoirs
entre l'état et les syndicats
ça veut dire qu'en fait les
représentants les partenaires sociaux
seront amenés à faire à intervenir dans
la gestion mais que toutes les décisions
reviendront au gouvernement et aux pas
sous le contrôle du parlement je crois
que c'est vraiment quelque chose quelque
chose d'important et je crois qu'il faut
s'en féliciter
j'ajouterai que contrairement à ce qui a
été dit par monsieur bartolone
l'effort est parfaitement réparti très
équitablement et je trouve que pour une
fois les socialistes pourraient
peut-être sur un sujet aussi important
ne pas polémiquer et trouvez qu'on va
dans le bon sens parce qu'au fond c'est
ce qu'ils ont cherché à faire qu'ils
sont arrivés alors on va maintenant
entendre d'autres réactions celle des
syndicats
d'ores et déjà la cgt appelle à une
journée de lutte le 28 novembre prochain
date à laquelle d'ailleurs force
ouvrière avait déjà appelé à une grève
interprofessionnelle réactions
syndicales donc en commençant par le
patronat le cnps monsieur endroit nous
apprécions que les déficits ce soir
essentiellement réduit par des économies
sur les dépenses aussi malgré les
charges qui à court terme vont peser sur
tous le patronat jouera tout son rôle
pour que cette réforme soit mise en
oeuvre avec rapidité et vigueur pour le
remboursement de la dette et pour la
modification de la csg 65 milliards
supplémentaires vont être ponctionnés
sur les assurés sociaux c'est à dire les
salariés les retraités les chômeurs pour
nous il n'y a qu'une seule réponse ça
n'est pas acceptable et nous sommes
persuadés que les assurés sociaux
entendront notre appel et
créeront les conditions avec nous pour
faire par exemple de la journée du 28
novembre
une puissante journée de lutte avec
toutes les organisations syndicales
en tout cas nous allons y travailler et
nous restons vigilants nous respondi
terminée nous ne le voulons pas le pied
nous ne donnons pas de chèque en blanc
au gouvernement nous ne lui faisons
faisons pas confiance a priori
aujourd'hui il a pris une bonne
direction il faut qu'il maintienne le
cap il faut qu'ils le gardent quand on
est content et sur la cfdt pour l'y
pousser dernière réaction celle de
monsieur marc blondel de force ouvrière
qui va participer ce soir à la marche du
siècle consacré justement à cette
réforme de la sécurité sociale or
monsieur blondel d'abord votre
appréciation disant d'ensemble au
terrible une révolution absolument
exceptionnelle l'état est en train de
voler faire main basse sur la sécurité
sociale
c'est effectivement quelque chose de
très important
je précise simplement que les
parlementaires ont discuté de l'argent
notre argent celui des cotisations
sociales
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
généralement ils parlaient de
l'affectation de l'impôt et bien ce soir
on a décidé une fois pour toutes que la
sécurité sociale obéirait aux
orientations du parlement alors je ne
suis pas sûr que ça correspond désir des
citoyens et des assujettis de la
sécurité sociale possible on a bien
autre chose qui doit vous irriter c'est
la surveillance disons plus étroite du
fonctionnement des caisses qui jusqu'à
présent étaient dix ans un face à face
entre partenaires sociaux patronat
syndicats de l'autre sans intervention
de l'état c'est la logique c'est le sait
je dirais la deuxième étape
maintenant nous allons avoir un conseil
de surveillance avec les députés
et maintenant nous allons avoir des
conseils tripartite comme l'a fait
justement remarquer madame veil ça veut
dire c'est l'état qui décidera
nous serons en quelque sorte l'élément
subsidiaire de la décision de l'état je
trouve que c'est une orientation
nouvelle mais c'était pas dans les
traditions de notre démocratie française
c'est une véritable petite révolution ça
mérite d'être regardée dans le détail et
sera des conséquences j'ajoute au
passage que dans le discours très
important de monsieur le premier
ministre il est fait état de la remise
en cause notamment des pensions pour les
fonctionnaires
or les pensions pour les fonctionnaires
sur les transforma retraite on remet en
cause
ça tue des gens public on remet en cause
le statut des fonctionnaires
je suis sûr que ceux ci seront répondre
à cette provocation alors monsieur blanc
d'un monsieur baroin n'est pas d'accord
avec vous mais vous lire dans un instant
dernière chose les cotisations retraite
prolongé à 40 ans d'annuités pour les
fonctionnaires comme dans le privé
d'ailleurs contre 37 ans et demi jusqu'à
présent vous avez fait remarquer tout à
l'heure que lorsqu'on l'a imposée pour
le le secteur privé on a mis cinq ans
pour réussir ça veut dire que nous
n'étions pas très heureux on va le faire
pour les fonctionnaires et si je suis
bien que si je suis bien renseigné ça ne
va d'ailleurs pas remporté grand chose
mais le problème peut se poser de savoir
si en ce moment où en principe on
devrait avoir comme souci premier
l'emploi et bien c'est en faisant
travailler les gens le plus longtemps
possible qu on dégagera les emplois
corrélativement on va faire 40 milliards
pour la cee corps et corrélativement on
va faire aussi des incitations diverses
pour le patronat je comprends d'ailleurs
que celui ci soit satisfait et nous nous
allons mettre 40 ans pour avoir une
retraite à peu près plein ce qui veut
dire que les jeunes qui rentreront dans
le marché du travail maintenant 25 ans
il n'y en a pas beaucoup qui auront une
retraite qui sera total alors monsieur
blondel réaction de monsieur barreaux
d'abord deux choses la première avec
tout le respect que je porte à marc
blondel
je veux lui dire qu'il da il faut qu'il
relise le discours d'alain juppé il
n'est pas question de remettre en cause
les droits des fonctionnaires celi
simplement de faire une opération clarté
entre les différents régimes de retraite
des français et c'est logique c'est ce
qui nous permettra de pas nous
chamailler à la française mais d'arriver
à voir un petit peu comment qui peut y
avoir une égalité de tous devant la
retraite et je crois que les
fonctionnaires nyon qui ont intérêt
alors je lui dis très simplement et très
amicalement
deuxièmement je ne crois pas que nous
allions vers l'étatisation je n'aurais
pas été partisan d'étatisation mais je
crois que c'est dans la france
d'aujourd'hui la sécurité sociale
programme france d'aujourd'hui il faut
combiner le pour la démocratie sociale
disons le rôle très important des
partenaires sociaux et puis le rôle des
représentants politiques élues
démocratiquement il faut le composent et
paul articulé et je crois que c'est pas
et attisé que d'essayer d'articuler
les deux pouvoirs bien en tout cas
blondel oui oui quand même
winch 2 du discours de monsieur le
premier ministre au nom de la justice
nous engagerons la réforme des régimes
spéciaux de retraités il s'agira de
préciser les mesures nécessaires à
l'équilibré régime et notamment des
modalités d'allongement de 37 ans et
demi à 40 ans ensuite il s'agira en
second lieu de prévoir la création d'une
caisse de retraite des agents de la
fonction publique de l'état
ça c'est la privatisation en quelque
sorte de la retraite des fonctionnaires
ça veut dire très exactement la remise
en cause du statut monsieur barreaux le
sait très bien
mais déjà les témoins moussilou peu
triste parce que oui dans cette
déclaration ce qu'on a simplement oublié
c'est que la sécurité sociale en général
souffrait du chômage et non l inverse
on la rend responsable du chômage quand
en fait c'est parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
chômeurs qui elle a des difficultés
un message a été selon lui monsieur
blondel vous pourrez continuer cette
discussion tout à l'heure puisque vous
participer tous les deux à la marche du
siècle sur une autre chaîne de france
télévisions la troisième chaîne un mot
peut-être monsieur bart ou simplement
non j'ajouterai simplement que en
matière de retraites il faut quand même
que nous essayons d'aller vers une
égalité d'accès mais il s'agit de de
condamner personne et quand la santé je
veux revenir sur ce carnet de suivi
médical
c'est tout simplement un moyen encore
une fois de de permettre à chaque
médecin et à chaque malade d'établir
cette relation de confiance qui est de
responsabilité qui fait partie du
contrat avec l'az égoïsme social est
vraiment ou simplement pour un dossier
médical qui a déjà été instauré par les
personnes âgées atteintes de plusieurs
pathologies
l'idée c'est que toi mon pour pouvoir
être remboursés il faudra avoir présenté
le dos le dossier médical c'est que
comme les gens qui les patients n'aime
jamais que leur propre médecin voit
qu'ils ont été voir quelqu'un d'autre
il nie roux bien il succombe à
rembourser s'ils vont voir quelqu'un
d'autre ou bien ils ont bien merci
beaucoup en tout cas merci de nous avoir
éclairé sur ce réforme dont nous auront
largement l'occasion de reparler
les autres titres de l'actualité le
ministre de l'éducation monsieur bayrou
a su aujourd'hui que son plan d'urgence
toucherait tous les établissements en
difficulté
lutter pour l'instant les problèmes 10
ans se règle au cas par cas l'université
d'orléans a reçu l'assurance aujourd'hui
d'une nouvelle dotation financière un
million donc dès aujourd'hui marie
pierre farkas à l'insa orléans un campus
paysager pour 17 700 étudiants des
bâtiments neufs n'est pas de crédits
pour les faire fonctionner le président
de cette femme a obtenu lundi une
enveloppe d'urgence au ministère
il est rentré tout pierre dans son
université le fait de donner une
enveloppe permet en c'est vrai que c'est
un secours ponctuel mais
particulièrement utile pour les re cité
qui ont des difficultés comme la mienne
ça c'est une chose mais je crois que
partir de là il est important qu'il y
ait je prends un dialogue au plus proche
avec le ministère sur l'évolution des
moeurs citer leurs problèmes leurs
besoins à la mi journée le président
reconnaît qu'il a eu du mal à faire
comprendre aux étudiants qu'un million
de francs c'était providentiel mais
aujourd'hui mercredi 14h ce qu'on veut
c'est les modifications que les
revendications de départ c'est-à-dire
qu'ils mans 14 lyon jusqu'en décembre
pour finir l'année
c'est à dire qu'il manque 2 160 postes
ces deux postes enseignants et c'est à
dire qu'il manque 200 postes iatos riz
prévu en théorie et qui n'ont toujours
pas éteint depuis 117 voix contre 13
pour 5 abstentions
le mouvement se poursuit donc
14h30 les enseignants annoncent en
assemblée générale que non plus ne sont
pas satisfaits qu'ils ne reprendront pas
les cours avant vendredi 16 heures
un millier de manifestants réclament un
franc symbolique au péage histoire de
poursuivre leurs études et
précise-t-elle usagers que le malaise
d'étudiants mais pas simplement une
question d'argent
j'ajoute à cela que ce soir les
étudiants de paris 8 saint denis appelle
à une grève illimitée et que le second
degré c'est-à-dire les lycées appellent
à se joindre au supérieur pour une
journée d'action le mardi 21 novembre
prochain le père d'un des deux pilotes
abattus au dessus de la bosnie en août
dernier le lieutenant souvigné s'adresse
à l'opinion publique afin qu'on n'oublie
pas son fils ni son camarade d'ailleurs
le capitaine scifo christophe tortora
vingt cinq buts depuis le 30 août
depuis que leurs mirage a été abattu au
dessus de la bosnie on ne sait pas ce
que sont devenus le capitaine frédéric
sipho et le lieutenant josé souvigny
opération militaire mission diplomatique
médiation du comité international de la
croix rouge
rien n'y fait les serbes de bosnie ont
reconnu avoir capturé les deux aviateurs
mais affirme que des inconnus les ont
enlevés par la suite des nouvelles qui
n'en sont pas vraiment le père du
lieutenant souvignet comme les autres
parents attend toujours et sympa sans
verdure la traque des pilotes afin dé
des officiers qui sont retombés à
l'heure est au constat n'est pas vous
avez eu des nouvelles de votre fils
depuis soixante quinze jours maintenant
au niveau
aucune nouvelle ni les militaires ni le
gouvernement personne n'était d'accord
les contempteurs pas sur vous les aurez
peut-être mais est-ce qu'il vous
contacte dont il trouvait ça normal
non non c'est à dire de la sono ils
savent pas où ils sont voilà comment est
ce que vous vivez cette situation
nouvelle crise trop par l'intermédiaire
de l'est républicain qui les soutient
les deux familles ont reçu à ce jour
plus de 47000 témoignages de soutien
mais ce sont des nouvelles de leurs
enfants qu'elle préférait lui
la politique maintenant avec ce titre
communiste la mutation le secrétaire
général du pc français monsieur robert
hue présenté aujourd'hui son livre édité
chez stock signes de mutation
supplémentaires la présentation avait
lieu dans un grand magasin parisien
françoise david michel jeannot latence
donc nous avons le plaisir le but livres
entre les piles des derniers prix
littéraires et les livres pour enfants
un homme politique qui dédicace son
dernier ouvrage signe particulier
l'auteur et le secrétaire général du pc
son livre s'intitule communisme la
mutation signe des temps peut-être pour
la première fois un dirigeant communiste
rencontre ses lecteurs dans un grand
magasin longtemps considéré comme le
symbole du capital et c'est nouveau et
c'est l'excellente initial qui tous les
cas cela élargira l'audience je crois
que c'est ce qui laissait faire un petit
moment pour vous c'est plutôt les grands
magasins qui se met à la page plutôt que
le parti communiste
moi je pense que si votre parti est
entre deux signatures quelques conseils
à la jeune génération
il faut encore travailler pour de
nombreux anciens communistes qui lisent
ce regard nouveau sur le parti
communiste sur la façon dont ils
avancent aujourd'hui avec sa politique
nouvelle cette mutation qu'il est bien
décidé d'entreprendre
ça nous intéresse après cette séance
inédite des rues renouera avec la
tradition de nombreuses réunions autour
de son livre sont prévues nous en des
lieux plus vite
l'actualité internationale arrestation
en israël aujourd'hui d'une étudiante
qui serait un membre important du
complot contre le premier ministre
monsieur itzhak rabin par ailleurs ce
soir monsieur shimon peres a été
officiellement chargé de former un
nouveau gouvernement en espagne jusqu'à
présent seul le premier ministre
monsieur philippe gonzalez était aux
prises avec des scandales financiers au
sein de son gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'est le roi lui-même qui est
directement visée dorothée olliéric
pascal stelletta alors de l'apéritif les
bars de la place à mayer sont toujours
très fréquent prix aujourd'hui un seul
sujet de conversation le chantage visant
le roi juan carlos il y a bien quelques
détracteurs mais surtout beaucoup
d'adorateurs leroy sera meilleur le
problème se son entourage
ceux qui prennent le pognon que vous
pensez que cela peut porter préjudice à
l'image du roi oui bien sûr dans ces
histoires il reste toujours quelque
chose
on peut dire il est innocent mais
peut-être qu'il ne l'est pas
il ya un doute c'est vrai il ya toujours
la possibilité qu'il soit coupable de
quelque chose mais ça on ne le saura
jamais c'est par isabelle et son mari
rosset que le scandale est arrivé
dans leur livre le pillage de l'espagne
ils ont rendu publique la tentative de
chantage fait par les deux ex financier
milliardaire
jadis cité comme exemple sous le
gouvernement socialiste
javier della rossa et mario compte des
ces deux hommes prétendent disposer de
preuves suffisantes impliquant
l'entourage du roi pour contraindre le
monarque abdiqué une sombre histoire de
peau de maquis ce chiffre tout de même à
500 millions de francs
depuis plusieurs jours isabelle fait la
une de tous les journaux à la radio s
explique nous on tient à dire que le roi
n'a pas céder à ce chantage c'est vrai
les financiers ont tenté de faire
pression mais l'image du roi pour nous
n'a pas dé tessalit dans cette affaire à
dire de la russa depuis des mois les
scandales financiers éclaboussent le
gouvernement socialiste espagnol
mais c'est la première fois que le nom
de juan carlos i est mêlé et même si le
monarque est victime d'un complot
politique
le mal est fait et le doute maintenant
existe je reviens à l'instant la
politique intérieure française après l
annonce de la réforme de la sécurité
sociale est bien à l'instant même
les sept fédérations de fonctionnaires
viennent d'appeler c'est encore
officieux mais de sources bien informées
à une grève le 24 novembre prochain
spécial algérie comme promis dans les
titres à la veille du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle en algérie
demain 16 millions sur les 28 millions
d'algériens sont appelés à voter pour
élire un président de la république
c'est le premier scrutin de ce genre
depuis 1962 depuis l'indépendance en
fait demain il ne s'agira pas d'élire un
candidat unique
mais le choix est à faire entre quatre
prétendants à la veille de cette
consultation menacé vous le savez par
les intégristes qui appellent au boycott
les algériens prennent leurs précautions
thierry thuillier hervé brusini bruno
girodon
depuis ce matin à alger les barrages
sont plus nombreux les fouilles de
véhicules à la recherche d'armes ou
d'explosifs plus systématique gendarmes
et policiers au pair le plus souvent
ensemble
cinquante mille réservistes ont même été
rappelé avec une mission assurer le bon
déroulement des opérations de vote
tu dois recommencer demain en dépit des
rumeurs les boutiques d'alimentation
sont ouvertes les files d'attentes pas
beaucoup plus longue qu'à l'habitude
bref l'apparence vous normal on stocke
d'autres aliments mais pas le pain dans
cette algérois la famille nombreuse
voilà pourquoi on en achète beaucoup
dans les stations services en revanche
les véhicules sont plus nombreux qu'à
l'accoutumée ont fait le plein par
précaution on ne sait jamais il
cherchait du mazout
parce que personne ne sait ce qui va se
passer demain c'est le bon dieu seul qui
le sait alger ne vit donc pas dans la
peur d'un déchaînement de violence
mais ici l'habitude conduit à se
préparer à tous y compris aux pires des
algériens vivant en france sont encore
voter aujourd'hui ils continueront
demain toute la journée et en algérie lé
dispositif électoral de cette première
élection à caractère démocratique même
s'il est contesté par certains est
véritablement bien mise en place et de
scrutin sera surveillé d'ailleurs par
des observateurs des nations unies et de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
brûlant le break
il se sent bien seul le gardien de la
mairie de birkhadem dans la banlieue
d'alger
et pour cause le bâtiment n'est plus
utilisable depuis que l'explosion d'une
voiture piégée l'a ravagé le 4 septembre
dernier
désormais surveillé de près par les
forces de l'ordre les différents
services de l'hôtel de ville se sont
installés dans des locaux provisoires
à la veille du scrutin présidentiel
priorité a été donnée aux services
électoraux les attentats ne doivent pas
gêner une population qui ont nous
l'assurent désir massivement voté l'an
passé dans mon enregistré 400 sacs
entiers nouvelles inscriptions durant
toute l'année
sa passagère a été doublé a été
multiplié par dix
ce qu'on nous avons enregistré 4160 et
on fait tout pour encourager le vote
cette jeune femme a été embauchée pour
apporter leur carte d'électeur à ceux
qui ne sont pas venus la chercher une
activité dangereuse qui justifie qu'elle
souhaite garder l'anonymat
elle se déplace seul à pied dans une
cité où les opposants à ce scrutin sont
très influents du même registre de la
mairie j'espère qu'elle est en plus je
marchais seuls les gens que je vais voir
ils ont peur aux açores travail
premièrement au deuxièmement en algérie
libre arrêter toute cette violence
symbole de l'algérie déchirée
cette femme risque sa vie pour que cette
élection soit un succès d'autres sont
prêts à la perdre car il n'y voit que de
faux espoirs fini dont je le disais tout
à l'heure la candidature unique du fln à
l'élection du chef de l'état demain il y
aura quatre candidats en lice dont
l'actuel chef de l'état le général
liamine zeroual bruno le dreff chef de
l'état en fonction liamine zeroual 54
ans n'a pas été élu à ce poste mais
nommé le 30 janvier 94 par le haut
conseil de sécurité c'est donc une
légitimité populaire qu'il recherche à
travers cette élection
considéré comme le favori du scrutin cet
ancien général s'est prononcé pour un
dialogue avec toutes les sensibilités
tout en réaffirmant sa détermination à
éradiquer les groupes armés marc bodnar
53 ans est un religieux avec son parti
le hamas proche des frères musulmans
égyptiens
il affecte de prôner ce qu'on appelle en
occident un islam modéré et assure qu
avec lui
l'algérie ne vivra pas sous l'étroit
contrôle de la charia la loi islamique
il dit sa volonté de réhabiliter le fils
et d'engager le dialogue avec les
extrémistes
militant de la cause islamiste depuis
toujours il a connu la prison sous la
présidence de houari boumédiène au
premier tour de 1991 son parti a obtenu
4,71 % des voix
comme nanar saïd sadi 48 ans a connu la
prison il militait alors pour la cause
berbère
il y côtoyaient les fondateurs du fils
madani et belhadj qui sont devenus ses
principaux ennemis politiques
ça dit avec son mouvement le
rassemblement pour la culture et la
démocratie est en effet le seul des
quatre candidats a prôné une rupture
radicale avec les islamistes partisans
de la démocratie et de la laïcité son
parti avait obtenu 2,56 % des voix en
1991 le moins connu des quatre candidats
nordine fouquereau 45 ans milite pour
une symbiose entre islam et modernité
ancien fonctionnaire il s'est engagé
dans l'islam politique
après avoir rencontré l'ayatollah
khomeiny à téhéran en 1970 son parti
algérien du renouveau obtenu 0,84 pour
cent des suffrages en 1991
l'élection sur fond de violences et même
de guerre civile et ne se passe
pratiquement pas une journée en algérie
sans qu'une bombe explose qu'un homme
politique un journaliste un intellectuel
ne soit assassiné mais les femmes et les
hommes de la rue mais aussi un tribut
très cher à cette vague de violence pour
s'en convaincre il n'ya qu'à visiter les
cimetières
thierry thulliez bruno girodon jihan el
tahri
alignés et récemment creuser les tombes
des bannis ils sont parfois très jeunes
omar avait 19 ans ces morts là ont été
ensevelis à l'écart au bout du cimetière
tout près de la prison
et pour tout épitaphe ont reçu un numéro
c'est l'état qui les a enterrés ce sont
ceux qu'on appelle ici des terroristes
des islamistes et les autres tous tués
par les forces de sécurité y compris mes
trois enfants
le dernier n'avait que 14 ans ils n'ont
rien fait dans le même cimetière voisine
mais si différentes les pierres tombales
des victimes des assassinats attribués
aux islamistes
il y a là des hommes politiques des
intellectuels des policiers et des
gendarmes
parmi eux beaucoup de jeunes
personne que le père a perdu ses deux
fils l'un des deux était policier
l'autre est tombé sous les balles
d'inconnus
personne ne lui a rien dit sur les
raisons de sa mort en algérie
la violence est aussi cacher la famille
yama dit elle
c'est pourquoi un père et son fils ont
été assassinés une famille d'anciens
moudjahidine connu pour ses positions
anti islamiste est une cible pour les
groupes armés il faut pas crier en
déclarant qu on doit pas être rancunier
envers ceux qui nous ont fait du mal
comme cdag rien pardonné peut-être mais
je vous dis c'est ça on doit continuer à
aimer ce pays
le peuple
oui à cet instant du journal je me dois
quand même de vous signaler que nous
voulions vous présenter cette page
spéciale en direct d'alger mais que cela
n'a pas été possible du fait des
autorités algériennes qui ont c'est le
mot qui convient censuré cette diffusion
poursuivons les femmes algériennes se
sont massivement impliqués dans cette
campagne présidentielle il ya toutes
celles qui sentent leur statut d'égalité
avec l'homme pour le moins menacée si ce
n'est déjà entamée nous avons tous en
tête les menaces des intégristes à
l'encontre par exemple de l'athlète fait
de la tête femmes hassiba boulmerka qui
il était reproché d'apparaître en tenue
de sportive cela dit il existe aussi des
femmes opposées à ce vote l'une de nos
équipes a rencontré l'une d'entre elles
françois jeu aujourd'hui se lever le
matin pour aller faire ses courses sur
ce qui fait de ses enfants allaient
travailler avec étudiants c'est faire
preuve de croire aujourd'hui vivre c'est
une preuve de courage vivre normalement
ne pas sombrer dans la dépression ne pas
ne pas fuir ne pas ne pas abandonner
complètement ne pas sombrer dans la
folie c'est cette une preuve de courage
je crois que effectivement les femmes
l'ugtt d'autant qu'elles ont beaucoup à
perdre et salima reali sait de quoi elle
parle
une des seules femmes rédactrice en chef
d'un hebdomadaire à alger elle lui
pratiquement dans la clandestinité
depuis plus d'un an pour des raisons de
sécurité il y à 48 heures son journal la
nation a été saisi par les autorités
algériennes la troisième fois en un mois
un journal et une femme qui dérange trop
indépendante trop critique
elle a choisi de boycotter l'élection
présidentielle et dénonce la violence
des politiques de tous bords la grosse
supercherie très souvent des hommes
politiques
lacoste supercherie et ils servent au
pape la fameuse et hom mes enfants et
intellectuels et autres c'est qu'il est
possible d'appeler à la guerre et d'en
attendre autre chose que du sang que de
l'horreur et de la barbarie
c'est pour ça que de mon principe
premier c'est de se battre pour la paix
quand salima razali parle de paix elle a
conscience que beaucoup de femmes comme
cette journaliste assassiné à la sortie
de son domicile sont mortes pour avoir
refusé de se taire alors résisté à la
violence en algérie c'est aussi parfois
pour toutes ces femmes tout simplement
continuer à afficher une certaine
coquetterie
quant à celles qui portent le hidjab le
voile islamique
elles sont peut-être un peu plus
nombreuses mais principalement dans les
quartiers populaires où la pression
islamique est la plus forte
on saura demain avec le pourcentage de
votants si les menaces des intégristes
qui appellent au boycott ont porté mais
déjà en algérie il y à un signe de leur
échec provisoire il avait exigé la
fermeture de toutes les écoles sauf les
écoles coraniques bien entendu et bien
malgré les attentats et les assassinats
d'enseignants elles sont restées
ouvertes
bruno le dreff même dans les lycées
protéger des quartiers chics d'alger il
est une question à laquelle on ne répond
pas facilement
ne faut-il pas être très courageux pour
continuer à suivre les cours
la question est pourtant toute simple la
réponse également
j'ai peur donc vous avez une
appréhension chaque matin quand je vois
une voiture je me demande toujours là
bas si c'est pas un attentat qui se
prépare sa mère l'algérie ya les filles
voilées pour aller à l'école
ce fut le premier mot d'ordre
et mr islamique puis ils voulurent
interdire l'école laïque à tous par
dizaines par centaines dans tout le pays
les bâtiments furent incendiés les
enseignants menacent et leurs élèves aux
si cela ne suffisait pas alors l'an
dernier ils allèrent jusqu'à abattre une
jeune lycéenne dans sa classe elle avait
15 ans mais tous ont résisté enseignants
comme élèves les classes mal équipés
sont même souvent encore plus bondés
qu'avant de croître de 50 élèves par
classe comme dans ce lycée d'alger à
cela il ya une raison établissement a
reçu des élèves d'établissements ça va
passer en attendant que ça passe chaque
jour simplement en allant au lycée 5
millions de jeunes algériens disent non
à la violence et à la mort à travers ses
reportages philippe harrouard nous avons
essayé de dresser le portrait de
l'algérie aujourd'hui à la veille de
l'élection présidentielle il nous faut
maintenant situé les enjeux et la valeur
du scrutin demain alors il faut le dire
et le répéter c'est la première élection
présidentielle en algérie avec plusieurs
candidats la question qui se pose ce
soir cette élection sera t-elle crédible
malgré la terreur et les appels au
boycott le taux de participation sera
t-il suffisant pour légitimer le scrutin
l'impressionnante mobilisation des
algériens de france n'est pas en soi une
réponse suffisante en algérie même la
population vit depuis quatre ans dans la
violence des pressions les intimidations
aura-t-elle le courage de surmonter ses
peurs
si oui elle pourrait marquer par son
bulletin de vote son ras-le-bol face une
situation de plus en plus insupportable
un indice prometteur
la campagne électorale a été un réel
succès chacun des quatre candidats
puissent s'exprimer devant bon nombre de
leurs
supporter sans problème majeur une autre
question est de savoir si le candidat
arrivé en tête ne sera pas suspectée de
tricherie ou de manipulation ce qui
détruirait le bien fondé du processus
électoral enfin dernière question le
pouvoir sortie des urnes sera-t-il en
mesure de conduire l'algérie vers une
voie démocratique et pacifique
c'est le pari est comme tout paris il
comporte des risques
voilà donc la page spéciale algérie que
nous voulions vous présenter ce soir la
plus complète possible malgré quelques
empêchements de la part je vous le
disais tout à l'heure des autorités
algériennes dans quelques instants la
météo puis le film quant à nous on se
retrouve demain soir à 20h bonne soirée
sur notre chaîne à l'homme